[Applause]
[Music]
what
so I'm
here you all about the deep in the night
do you even earn that in a
[Music]
year are we living in the midst of power
oh we living in the final hour there's
always sweet and S so
we
going you
chasing he's a miserable shitty
wait
wait I'm good
for I can get you the money
[Music]
stand watching out every why would
happen if you took it
[Music]
away jealous the B isn't moving slow
I'll tell you all the story about the
joke around
[Applause]
Gentlemen The Royal Hospital somewhat
proudly presents Dr rainford
sne and the much celebrated Dr Jack
Dawkins now we have a fine one for you
today jent leg shattered falling down a
m Shar was
it the question though is who cuts
heads
me I bet you can't do under 43 pound
says 29 when have you ever had him pound
as soon as you lose
gentlemen Dr sne here seems to think
that I can't amputate this leg in less
than his record of 43
seconds I beg to differ
Mr shlow this will be the worst 30
seconds of your life but I promise I
will make it as quick as I can your
favorite
memory take your mind there
[Music]
[Applause]
now
timing